this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
hey guys it's max in front of me I have
two excellent laptops I have the 2020
13-inch MacBook Pro this is the 4
Thunderbolt port model and I also have
the 2020 Dell XPS 90 300 Dell made a ton
of improvements with this machine and
today we not only are gonna be comparing
things like the CPU and graphics
performance we're also going to talk
about keyboards trackpads displays
webcams certain extra features that Dell
offers that make it really compelling
and I have to say that if you're trying
to decide between these two there's
never been a more difficult choice but
at the end we are gonna help you guys
decide so let's go ahead and start out
with the exteriors of these devices if I
pull up this display you guys could see
that the delos is shorter and that is
because Dell has this beautiful thin
bezel it is so slim on the sides on the
top as well even though they're packing
in more Hardware up over here where
Apple they didn't change the design it
we didn't get a 14 inch unfortunately it
looks identical not bad at all but it
does look dated compared to the Dell now
if I go ahead and fold these and I'm
gonna stack them up on top of each other
you guys can see that the Dell is not as
wide not as long the MacBook Pro is
quite a bit bigger the thicknesses are
similar and the weight is fairly similar
the Dell is a little bit lighter but not
by that much and the Dell also has a
different shape
the MacBook Pro is quite boxy whereas
Dell uses more of a slate shape just
like the MacBook Air now you guys might
also notice that the Dell has one port
over here and a micro SD card slot I'm
glad they added that in Apple if you
don't want to do full size please I know
you're not gonna do it but it would be
great
Apple has two Thunderbolt three ports on
the side here and if we flip to the
other side as I mentioned this is the
four Thunderbolt port model so you have
four full-speed that are both three
ports where Dell only offers you two now
if you buy the base MacBook Pro it does
also have two but if you spend the extra
money to get a higher config it's nice
to have those extra ports in case you
want to hook up to more displays docks
accessories where Dell you only get one
now if we take a look at the bottom
apple
has these long cut outs over here that
allows air to get sucked in Dell also
has some and they made some changes for
2020 they may be the edge get curved
more so there's less chance of this
being blocked and Dell has some speakers
right here as well their bottom firing
and then another set of air intakes
right over here these can get blocked if
it's on your lap or even worse on a
blanket say something like that where
there's not as much risk of that with
the MacBook Pro and overall if I'm just
going to talk about the build quality
tell is just as good as Apple or very
close they really stepped it up this is
all aluminum now instead of having
plastic sandwich in between you guys can
see right here it's all milled out it
feels excellent it is super rigid even
if we open it up there's very little
display flex chassis flex they are
keeping up with Apple Apple does feel a
bit more premium because it is all
aluminum you don't have any soft touch
over here so it feels a little bit nicer
and more premium whereas the Dell it has
rubber now here's another difference as
I open this up you guys might just
notice that it locked me in
automatically and that is because this
has Windows hello built in there's extra
sensors just like on your iPhone with
face ID that projects little dots it
reads it's fairly secure and it's really
really quick I love that I wish Apple
out of that but they didn't so we'll get
back to webcams in the quality in just a
bit but taking a look at the design here
the Dell is just much more compact and
even though this soft touch doesn't feel
as premium it is more comfortable
doesn't get as cold but it does pick up
fingerprints and grease a little bit
easier than the Mac now even though Dell
gave us that Windows hello facial
authentication they still included a
fingerprint scanner that's built into
the button just like apple with apple
you just have that touch ID we also have
some differences above on the sides the
MacBook Pro has this touch barb the
custom shortcuts I show up here will
change depending on what application you
have open you can customize them a bit
now as far as the keyboards Apple
finally upgraded they got rid of the
butterfly keys the new magic keyboard
has more travel it feels a lot nicer and
it's also gonna be more reliable it's a
great keyboard and Dell also upgraded
their keyboard they added more key
travel they made it
feel better honestly I can't tell you
what which one is which they both are
excellent and I don't think anybody's
gonna complain about these keyboards
they are fantastic now let's look a
little bit lower and compare the track
pads the Dells is a little bit smaller
but it's not small it's a standard track
pad but they did improve it compared to
last year and even though it is a diving
board design you could still click
fairly high and it is really good it's
one of the best windows track pads they
did a great job but appleís is better it
is larger it is all glass and it uses
magnets so it feels the same no matter
where you click it is an amazing
trackpad definitely better than the
Dells and now let's look a little bit
higher and compared to displays Apple
makes it easy there's only one display
option no matter even if you're getting
the base one it is there Retina display
just over 4 million pixels it looks nice
and sharp
whereas with Dell you have four options
the base is a 1080p spend another
hundred bucks you get a 1080p
touchscreen spend more you get a 4k and
the highest and one the one I have is a
4k display it is touchscreen Dells 4k
definitely looks more detailed than
Apple's 2.6 K or so because this has
over 9 million pixels compared to 4
million pixels it looks sharper and Dell
also allows this display to show HDR so
with this particular video I'm getting a
lot more pop in the snow it looks
fantastic it looks sharper but that
doesn't tell the whole story now both
these displays are actually 500 nits of
brightness Apple just doesn't think
that's enough brightness to do great HDR
so they don't enable it and Apple does
have better coatings for their display
so I'm seeing less reflectivity which is
nice Dell stepped it up for this year
but it still not as good and we do have
a difference in color accuracy Dell
screens can display 100% srgb color
accuracy which is good enough for most
people but all of Apple screens even the
base macro Pro can display DCI p3 colors
and if you guys see this little logo
right here
we're just saying one solid color on the
Dell whereas with the MacBook Pro we're
seeing this logo on the inside because
that shade cannot be displayed on Dells
display now along with the displays
there's one other important thing that
needs to be paired with it to give you a
good experience and that
the speakers but before we compare the
speakers let me give a shout out to the
sponsor of this video Squarespace if
you've been thinking about making your
own website now is the perfect time and
Squarespace is seriously the best way to
go you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience it doesn't matter if you want
a portfolio a blog ecommerce or anything
else you just choose a template and
customize blocks of text and images it's
incredibly simple affordable and ours
have been running flawlessly for over
two years now bringing in new clients
thanks to its built in SEO tools start
your free two week trial with no credit
card required by going to
squarespace.com slash max tag or by
using the custom link down below and
when you're ready to launch you'll save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain now it is time to compare
the speaker is make sure you guys go get
your best pair of headphones and before
we start I want to say that last year
this test was an embarrassment to the
XPS the previous XPS used one watt
speaker as one on each side and it seems
like they listened because this year
each speaker gets two and a half watts
that's a big big improvement but let's
see if it can compare to the MacBook Pro
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comments section below I'll
give you guys my opinion cuz I'm hearing
him live without YouTube compression and
all of that
well the dell improved a lot compared to
last year but it is still a not a
competition the macbook pro actually
peaked about 4 decibels higher based off
of my Apple watch and in general it's by
2 to 3 decibels louder I want to note
that this is the 4 thunderbolt port
model if you get the base model MacBook
Pro it doesn't have the built in the
woofers so it doesn't sound as good but
it still sounds slightly better than the
Dell XPS if you guys watch our previous
comparison with the extra woofers and
all the tuning it allows this other
other speakers to playback better and it
sounds better in every way the bass
sounds better the mid sound better the
highs are more clear and it's louder
overall I will say most people be happy
with the Dell XPS it's not like it's bad
like it used to be it's on average maybe
a little bit better but Apple just did a
fantastic job with these higher-end
13-inch MacBook Pros both of these
laptops feature 720p webcams this is
what you get as far as video quality and
microphone quality from the 2020 MacBook
Pro and this is the webcam and
microphone quality of the 2020 Dell XPS
you guys let me know any differences
that you noticed and which one looks and
sounds better let me know down in the
comments section below
one thing I can tell right away is that
the XPS the webcam is much much wider
you guys can see that that may or may
not be a good thing depending on how
clean your room is and stuff like that
and now let's get into performance we're
gonna start off testing the SSDs both of
these do have 512 gig SSDs I have aja
opened up here since it works on both
Mac and Windows let's go ahead and get
started ok so very interesting as far as
their write speeds they're basically
identical just over 2,300 and as far as
read we have 2400 MacBook Pro and 2563
slightly faster with XPS both of these
are super fast you won't notice the
difference but there is one difference
you will notice and especially down the
line and that's the fact that the XPS
allows you to upgrade your SSD later but
with Apple whatever you buy out of the
gate
is exactly where you're going to be
stuck with and now let's compare the CPU
and the graphics performance I opened up
Geekbench 5 and now's a good time to
mention that both of these have 16 gigs
of ram now both of these do have Intel's
10 generation of chips but we have a
couple differences for $1,800 Apple
actually gives you an i5 processor
whereas Dell gives you an i7 the clock
speeds though are different this I 7 is
at 1.5 gigahertz base where this i-5 is
at 2.0
Intel's starting to make the stuff
really confusing so we're gonna see what
happens in the real world so if we take
a look here we have our best performance
mode set you don't have that option on
the Mac Book Pro very interesting we're
about 3/4 of the way done and I hear the
XPS the fans kicked up not super loud be
here and whereas the macbook pro is
still silent the dell finished the test
first in the mac just spun up its fans
at the very end and it also finished up
here we have it wow that is that is
incredibly close 1227 compared 2267
but that is within margin of error on
multi-core 4408 vs. 44 89 also within
margin of error you'll get bigger
fluctuations than those differences if
you just run you know one test and then
do another test so i 5 vs i that i 7 but
the results are practically the same i'm
gonna go ahead and start our OpenCL test
and i want to say that both of these
laptops have g7 graphics even though
this is the i7 this is an i5 Apple
actually wins with the i5 that's paired
with the fastest graphics so this should
be very similar now if you get the
cheaper base $1300 MacBook Pro that
actually comes with an 8th gen Intel CPU
where the single core performance is
gonna be roughly 25 30 % worse than the
i5 that's cheaper for the XPS that's a
big difference
multi-core differences aren't as big but
also the graphics we have a difference
so do you no longer have Intel's latest
graphics and the dell will actually come
with g1 graphics the weakest of the
latest so what the
tell you absolutely want to go for the
i7 if you can afford it so as for now
BAM the del just got done ten thousand
eight hundred that's actually the
highest score I've seen the del get okay
and that's a very low OpenCL score
comparing comparatively so we have eight
thousand three hundred fifty three
compared to ten thousand eight hundred
that's probably about a twenty
twenty-five percent difference in
performance
now with the MacBook Pro if you're
running metal you're gonna get over ten
thousand as well I think our last test
was ten thousand four hundred most Apple
apps Mac apps they're using metal now
it's a lot more efficient and you're
gonna get better performance there
because it's tuned for that let's go
ahead and open up Unigine heaven it's a
gaming test and see how they compare so
it's been running for a few minutes here
and I definitely noticed a couple of
things
the MacBook Pro is running silent Iran
really silent for a while once it's
heated up now it's a 2600 rpm the Dell I
don't know what the RPMs are but it
definitely is much louder not
obnoxiously loud but you definitely hear
it the GPUs at 73 degrees Celsius
whereas the max temperature readouts at
72 similar temps but the Mac is running
quieter looks like we're almost done
with the test the MacBook Pro only got
up to three thousand rpms where's the
XPS constantly had that kind of low
noise but it wasn't obnoxious or
anything like that and as far as the
results thirteen point seven FPS
compared to thirteen point five
extremely extremely close I also want to
point out that if you're buying the base
MacBook Pro it actually has one fan and
set up to duel fans that's inside of
this model and in that case it will run
louder more similar to like what the XPS
is running right now now before we go
into our last test before we start
talking about prices and the verdict I
want to mention that I noticed the
difference here the case on the XPS are
definitely hotter on both sides over
here compared to the MacBook Pro you
still feel some heat here but it
definitely feels cooler than XPS in the
XPS fan it's been about two minutes
since the last test it's still running
get it even cooler it even with those
fans constantly running we're at 53
degrees Celsius 54 whereas our MacBook
Pros shut the fans off a couple minutes
ago it's running at 48 right now we're
gonna use Sena measure our 20 it's very
ancient cuz both these two have tension
now so it's finally more comparable
let's go ahead and run send a bunch our
20 I'm gonna be keep an eye out on Intel
power gadget and right off the bat we
just hit 39 did watts the Dell hit 43
watts Dell is pushing a lot of power the
Mac will get the same score if it's
unplugged the Dell usually it won't give
it as much wattage as high as it does
when it's plugged in as far as the
frequency is both at 3 gigahertz so that
looks pretty comparable this is 100
degrees Celsius and the Mac is at 100
degrees Celsius but both get hot very
fast and that's because the companies
want the max performance out of these
they're pushing a ton of wattage these
chips are rated at 15 but they get be
pushed 25 or higher at this point we're
at 26 watts
Dell is down to 24 99 degrees 97 degrees
very similar before the fans would ramp
up all the time and it would slow itself
down to get it to run cooler now it's
running at 90 97 90 degree Celsius
Dell is not caring as much about
allowing it to run ha they're trying to
maximize performance just like Apple
does at this point we're about halfway
done a little bit more both are running
at 99 98 degrees we're running a 2.6
gigahertz here compared to 2.9 and 3.0
right there once a fans kick up its
charged pushing more wattage to a more
electricity in the Dell definitely
kicked up its fans earlier than the Mac
at this point they're about the same
both get about the similar loudness if
you keep pushing the CPUs but the Mac
will try to keep that 3 gigahertz
compared to running at 2.6 and we have
our results here and Wow okay so we have
16 16 on the ducks yes roughly around
what we've got on our previous tests and
comparisons where's the Mac has 1911
that is close to 20% higher performance
that is really impressive and this just
proves that the whole I 5 and i7 thing
they don't really matter and before we
talk about prices where it gets a little
bit weird let's talk about battery life
now with the MacBook Pro I get seven to
eight hours of battery life I expect
this new one to be similar
now with the Dell XPS it gets a little
tricky because if you buy the Loren
model with a 1080p screen that doesn't
look as good as the MacBook Pro remember
microprose four million pixels the 1080p
will have a little bit more than two
million pixels that will actually get
about nine to ten hours of battery life
for mixed use that is excellent but if
you want to enjoy the gorgeous 4k
display that I have here doc drops you
down to five to six hours of mixed use
at about 350 units of brightness and now
let's talk about the prices I'm going to
start with a comparison of the exact
specs that I have here and then I'll
talk about lower and less expensive
options so for once with Apple upgrading
the SSD and giving you 16 gigs of ram
this is actually cheaper the MacBook Pro
comes in at $1,800
with the i5 CPU 512 SSD 16 gigs of ram
whereas the XPS it's running at $1,900
without 4k display now if you don't want
the 4k display it'll be the less
expensive but we're comparing kind of
quality more similar here now I have to
mention that dulse prices move around
quite a bit but it gets a little bit
more interesting when we go down and say
we want to add 32 gigs of ram which you
can on both these machines that costs
$400 on the MacBook Pro and with Dell it
costs 150 hundred fifty dollars less
than half the price and if you want to
get a one terabyte SSD that costs a
hundred bucks on the dough cost two
hundred on the Mac and if you want to
get two terabytes cost 300 on the Dell
$600 on the Mac and keep in mind you
could actually upgrade your SSD yourself
so upgrades from this point are cheaper
on the Dell and now let's compared the
base models apples base MacBook Pro
comes in at $1300 compared to Dells at
$1200 they're both I 5 processors and
the the dell actually has g1 graphics
and the MacBook Pro if you buy that bass
one it's using eighth generation chips
but the performance is actually very
similar when we're comparing graphics
and CPUs even though the macro uses
older chips now the Dell is $100 less
expensive but that includes that 1080p
display you can spend another hundred
bucks if you want a touch screen 1080p
and if you want a 4k display it's a $300
upgrade and if you guys want 16 gigs of
ram thankfully Apple now is only
charging $100 instead of the previous
200 same as Dell but upgrading to a 512
cost you 200 bucks on the Mac it costs
you 50 bucks on the Dell and you can
upgrade it yourself later so on the
Lauren model the Dell is more
competitive but keep in mind the display
is a lot worse if you care about that
type of stuff if you want to be doing
photo editing video editing it's nice to
have a sharp displayed and now for the
verdict which one should you spend your
money on well right off the bat
some people love mac OS and that's gonna
bring them to the MacBook Pro you can't
get mac OS on the XPS but you can
install windows easily on the MacBook
Pro in Africa pairing the base models
without any upgrades for a hundred bucks
more with the MacBook Pro you're gonna
have a great system you're gonna have
enough storage for most people it's
gonna be quieter the speakers are better
the trackpad is better the display is a
lot better than the 1080p panel on the
Dell it's gonna run quieter and on top
of that you're gonna have much better
resale value as well so I think if you
just want a base system the MacBook Pros
are no brainer the Dell definitely has
its upsides - I love the look I love how
sleek it is I love the changes they made
I love the windows hello that's not
enough to bring me to buying the Dell
now on the higher end when you're
comparing the models I have here the
MacBook Pro with tension is excellent
even with that and with the i-5 speakers
are way better it is quieter at the same
time once again resale value all those
things come in it's a great deal now if
you're somebody that is gonna be
upgrading a 32 gigs of ram upgrading to
a terabyte you're gonna have a big big
difference in the price of the systems
much less expensive to keep upgrading
the Dell
in that case if you like the sleek
design I think a lot of people will also
be happy with adult if they don't need
mac OS and tell us never made a laptop
this good and this is my favorite
Windows laptop right now we're gonna
have our review coming out soon make
sure you guys click that circle above to
subscribe so if some of these features
and things that the Dell offers are
attractive to you you don't care about
my quest pick it up you're gonna be very
happy with it we have some great videos
over there if you guys want to watch
them this Mad Max and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]